mark first question right here
Kawai mark Schwartz ESPN can you take me
through the final possession where a
good dollar hit the 3 there was about
five seconds left on the clock when he
took it 8 seconds left in the game and
he wound up being wide open and the
plays that took place before it were you
guys almost stole it
pretty much summed it up right there
we end up trapping curry
I was playing to 11 here in the past in
the Livingston almost got a steal and
then I mean I really didn't see where he
came from he came up the Piston found
him and he knocked on a shot big shot
did you want to see the ball in his
hands in that situation compared to
anybody else on the floor no we wanted
to see it in our hands we wanted to get
us to Robert on the right side Robert
lives how BSO right here at Kauai what
is the key you know and winning on the
road and it's such an important playoff
series in the finals you've done it
obviously before what are you considered
the key when you go on the road
especially now that you guys are 1 1
just coming in as one you know what I
mean
obviously on somebody else's home floor
you know I got the six man with the
crowd but you know just have to buy into
ourselves and you know come out hard
strong no mistakes no turnovers and you
know the same thing you got to do at
home third row here in the center Koharu
John was questi sports well how does it
feel to be the only player and to lead a
team to two different NBA conferences I
mean I never thought of it really but I
mean I guess it feels good but it's not
over yet still basketball and no matter
what Jersey you got on and you know
that's what I'm trying to do just lead
and win games
over here in the second row on the right
Kauai um when you look back at the game
in the body of work where did things
break down defensively for you guys and
how for like in that third quarter you
know we didn't score the ball and like
the first five minutes we're gonna have
minutes obviously led to him getting out
in transition early and you know a lot
of layups an open looks and I was pretty
much the game right there went on like
15 18 Oh Ryan I believe and you know you
can't do that what it would have a
championship team on either side I mean
you guys are really fast game one did
things kind of flip around game two I
mean I can't say that uh I mean I felt
like our pace was good early it's just
that third quarter I feel like it just
really killed us you know I mean 18
around we can't score no best cuz you're
not gonna win no game against a bro
tennis Amagi Eagle News Philippines the
Warriors have a lot of injuries will
that affect the your the team's
chemistry the Raptors chemistry or will
he do you feel that you will take
advantage of that hmm not really I mean
we still got to go out and make shots
and guard guys that's out there
everybody's in the NBA
these guys have a high basketball IQ I
mean you know obviously they're missing
Durant it's a big loss for him but I
mean they won the game tonight you any
other questions
Michael over here on the left side let
it go how much do you lean on just your
past experience in the finals and how
much did you share with your teammates
you know going in one one or going on
the road just obviously just taking one
game at a time you know
you know finals is not gonna be easy the
only thing that matters is the forward
Four Winds once you get it two wins
three wins it does not matter just take
one game at a time and you know just
play it through the adversity how much
was your respect girl for a team like
the Warriors just the fact that they
were able to get all those key plays
down the stretch I mean I mean it's a
big respect for him they've been here
the last four years
one alastu and I mean you gotta just
take the challenge
Greg basketball team you got to go out
there and accept the challenge and you
know wanna fight and win thank you quiet